imagine striking a match and having
everything around you catch on fire
even if you were standing in a wet
forest
and while that's happening imagine being
chased by giant insects
these are just a few of the things that
would happen if you lived in a world
where the atmosphere was pure oxygen
what other things would happen on earth
would you be able to survive this
this is what if and here's what would
happen if earth's atmosphere was pure
oxygen
oxygen takes up just over 20 percent of
our atmosphere the rest is mainly
nitrogen
it's no secret that you need oxygen it
allows us to breathe and it's
responsible for all forms of life
if there were no oxygen in the
atmosphere everything would die
including you
but what would happen if the atmosphere
was nothing but oxygen
at first it may sound like a good thing
oxygen is what helps us live and gives
our bodies energy
more of it has to be a good thing right
there are even oxygen bars all around
the world that offer hits of 95
oxygen
these services claim a number of things
from making you more productive at work
to being able to cure your hangover
if you were able to breathe one hundred
percent oxygen all the time
would it make you an extremely energetic
superhuman version of yourself
nope
not at all
too much oxygen is actually a bad thing
at a certain point it can be downright
poisonous for humans
if you breathe in too much oxygen too
fast it creates free radicals
free radicals are unstable atoms that
damage cells and they're linked to a
variety of diseases including cancer and
alzheimer's
they're also thought to be linked to
things like wrinkles and gray hair so if
we were able to survive an extended
period of time with pure oxygen in the
atmosphere we'd most likely appear much
older
but that could only happen if we evolved
and adapted to live in an oxygen-only
atmosphere
if it happened instantly your chest
would be hurting each time you took a
deep breath
fluid would accumulate in your lungs and
you'd start to become dizzy and
lightheaded
as you kept breathing your lungs would
begin to get damaged and so would your
brain
until you lost consciousness and died
for insects it might be a different
story
around 300 million years ago giant
insects roamed the earth
at that time the earth's atmosphere was
35 oxygen a lot more than the 20 we
breathed today
researchers suspect that the increased
oxygen was responsible for those giant
insects it had to do with the tracheal
system a network of tubes that brings
oxygen to the insect cells and takes
away carbon dioxide
if there was more oxygen in the
atmosphere the insects tracheas would
expand
and their bodies would get bigger
but what about those crazy fires we
mentioned before
well if you happen to survive long
enough to light a match you wouldn't
last too long after that
as soon as you brought your flame to
something anything it would instantly
catch fire in a massive explosion
you see oxygen is a key ingredient to
what makes a fire spread and expand
if we only had oxygen in our atmosphere
our fires would become massive
what was once a small campfire would now
be a fiery explosion
so even if you could breathe in an
atmosphere of pure oxygen
the giant insects and the earth burning
all around you would make life pretty
tough
even impossible
the only way to survive would be to
adapt and to make sure fires never
happened
what would your life be like without
fire
well that's a story for another what if
you